hospitals in india are launching
desperate appeals for help as the
country's health system crumbles
coronavirus infection rates continue to
break global records
the government has given top priority to
the transport of life-saving oxygen
but hospitals are so overwhelmed that
many people can't even get inside
the situation is particularly dire in
the capital delhi where oxygen supplies
are running out fast
fighting for breath these patients
outside a covet 19
hospital in delhi are among the
fortunate ones
the clinic is overwhelmed and lacks free
beds
but at least it still has oxygen to
administer to the most gravely ill among
a steady flow
of new arrivals the situation
right now here is really reversed
critical
and out of control
the staff is really cooperative but due
to the overcrowding
of the main hall of the walking casualty
it is
difficult to provide equal treatment to
all the patients
that's why there is a high casualty rate
inside
these scenes are no exception across the
country hospitals are full and turning
stricken patients away
many are critically low on oxygen
supplies as
india's second wave sets global records
for new daily infections
social media are flooded with stories of
people desperately trying to secure
oxygen for loved ones
[Music]
to speed up deliveries indian railways
has launched an oxygen express service
fairing supplies directly from
production plants
like a beacon of hope the first train
arrives in maharashtra
one of the hardest hit states where more
than 62 thousand people have lost their
lives to the virus
inside clinics grieving families blame
medical staff
while outside crematoriums and
cemeteries struggle to accommodate
bodies
this graveyard expects to run out of
space in a matter of days
i think this second wave is more
dangerous and deadly
this time it's not even sparing the
young ones
at the delhi hospital a group of men
heave their brother out of a rickshaw
they tried to get him admitted earlier
but were sent home
now they learn it's too late to save him
the father of five is dead on arrival
since he wasn't admitted to the hospital
or taken to its morgue his death is
unlikely to be counted
in the city's swiftly rising official
toll
well let's go straight to delhi now
where dw's amrita chima is standing by
amrita what is the situation like in
delhi today
the situation here rebecca is very very
difficult
we are getting sos calls from hospitals
all over the city
saying that they are running out of
oxygen they have just a few hours
of oxygen left in their hospitals in
fact 20 people died overnight in a
private hospital in delhi
simply because the hospital ran out of
oxygen people who want critical care
equipment just died because the hospital
didn't have any oxygen
left in its stores now of course there's
a great sense of desperation and anguish
in delhi right now there are people the
case the number of cases are spreading
so fast that possibly there's not a
single family in delhi
which has not been directly or
indirectly affected
by the rise in cases in this second
surge
and there's also rebecca a growing sense
of anger
as to why this has been dealt with the
way it has why isn't more oxygen
available
yeah the scenes certainly are horrific
i'm rita um
as we just saw in that report the first
trains delivering oxygen is there hope
that conditions
might improve soon well apart from the
the oxygen that you saw
are coming by train in your report
there's also oxygen coming by road
because you have various highways which
have been cleared
and declared as oxygen corridors to get
these oxygen tankers from different
parts of the country
to go to destinations where they are
most critically needed
at the same time you also have some air
force cargo planes
which are bringing oxygen cylinders to
places where they are most urgently
needed
so help is on the way but the second
problem rebecca is
distribution of this oxygen now india
has a federal structure
which means you have different states
and they're competing claims
between these states as to who needs
oxygen more
and then there's a difference between
states which are ruled by prime minister
narendra modi's bjp party and those
states
which are not and those which are not
run by the bjp are complaining
that they are not getting priority when
it comes to oxygen supplies so that is
another big issue
which is facing the country right now
now what about infections and what
measures
are being taken to try and stem the tide
of infections in india
rebecca at the moment the key priorities
really is just
oxygen more oxygen and oxygen but of
course
parallel parallel measures are being
taken for example
you know delhi is under curfew at the
moment day and night curfew
many other cities in the country
including mumbai which is also very hard
hit
has also put restrictions on people
moving around
um in addition to that the government is
of the national government prime
minister narendra modi's not keen
to impose a national lockdown like he
did last
year very quickly and very short notice
and that caused almost a humanitarian
disaster
in india so this time they're looking at
what they're calling micro
containment zones so where infections
are really high
you create a containment zone and
isolate people and isolate
those who are infected they're also of
course looking at
now vaccination was only in the
beginning for people
over a certain age of over 60 now from
the 1st of may
it's going to be open to anyone over the
age of 18.
so the government is hoping very much
that this will break the chain
of transmission but the conditions here
in delhi and rebecca are
really really tough and people literally
you get the sense of the
indian capital is gasping for breath
i am rita thank you very much for that
update i'm rita chima dw
delhi bureau chief